jackass forever is finally here but
which stunts are the cream of the crop
and which ones are cringe here's the
best and the worst the film has to offer
the opening scene of every jackass movie
has always been a truly insane
theatrical spectacle but jackass forever
makes its own mini monster movie to kick
things off
it's set in a city where most of the
casts are milling around when a kaiju
attacks well sort of of course like any
good monster flick a number of these
fine citizens get thrown around like
ragdolls whether it's an exploding
cinema that hurls wee man and dave
england in the air or steve-o getting
locked in a portaloo it's a wild
introduction to say any more would ruin
the brilliant absurdity of the whole
thing
the spider bowl is just pure nightmare
fuel no matter how you look at it the
premise is simple danger aaron and
constant dark shark wilson sit opposite
each other with their heads and helmets
that are connected by a tube and they
have to blow a tarantula into the other
person's helmet terrifying this one adds
a sinister level to the carnage because
it's a type of stunt that forces the
audience to imagine themselves in the
situation and yes the same can be said
for many jackass stunts but this one
just feels a lot more intense
especially when knoxville makes a point
of showing off the tarantula's fangs up
close which is a heck of a thing to see
on the big screen arachnophobes will not
have a good time with this one
jeff tremaine and the jackass crew have
always enjoyed designing elaborate gags
wherein the cast members think they're
doing one thing but really it's
something much much worse one such prank
is the snake room trick
they're each led into a room shown a
barrel that holds a deadly rattlesnake
also noting that they'll need anti-venom
if it bites them before the light goes
off and they're left in the dark what
they don't know is that the barrels are
swapped out and there is no snake just
the sneaky johnny knoxville who lurks in
the room with a pair of night vision
goggles it's a type of childish fun that
has always made jackass great as the
impish knoxville teases his friends by
throwing rubber snakes at them and
generally attacking them while they
can't see it only escalates when they
think they found an exit door away from
the snake room only to find themselves
in another dark room full of mouse traps
and thumbtacks it doesn't take a genius
to figure out what happens next
the only major problem jackass forever
has is the way it relies on riling up
different animals and insects to get a
laugh out of the audience sure watching
danger aaron get trapped in a room with
a bear as he's covered in honey and meat
is hilarious but it also feels
incredibly mean toward the bear the idea
is to tease the bear into eating the
food off of aaron while hoping to scare
the man half to death it's not exactly
the same as forcing the bear to dance
but it's not far off the same can also
be said for the tarantula in the spider
bowl it's getting blown through a tube
between two human beings which are
considerably larger than it of course
it's going to get angry there's also a
vulture that pecks at weeman's meat
covered crotch again it's incredibly
easy to laugh at but it does make you
feel a little sorry for the giant bird
it's worth noting that the animals
always get the last laugh when it comes
to these kind of stunts since they all
get to peck bite scratch or headbutt the
jackass boys and girls without
hesitation
sure the gang of pranksters thrive off
of torturing one another in varying
degrees of insanity but it's weirdly
wholesome they're all working together
to create something truly special the
act of pulling off absurd stunts and
pranks that are guaranteed to get a
laugh out of the audience they embody
that teenage sense of rebellion as they
find fun in doing stupid things simply
because they can and because they're
funny it's genuinely joyful to see them
pull off moments like an underwater fart
explosion because as ridiculous and
painful as some of the pranks and stunts
are they're all in it together on the
other side of the screen jackass forever
is the type of movie that truly unites
the audience because every time someone
slams into the ground after leaping from
a ramp or someone gets hit in the crotch
for the millionth time the collective
wince and capal brings everyone together
you heard it here first jackass forever
is one of the most wholesome movies of
2022. one concerning moment in jackass
forever comes when johnny knoxville once
again gets in the ring with a bull he's
done the stunt several times before but
the one in the fourth movie is no
laughing matter the performer is dressed
as a magician when the bull just plows
through him sending knoxville high into
the air upon landing the star breaks his
wrist the rib and also gets a severe
concussion it's painful to watch but
it's made worse by knoxville's comments
on the press tour for the movie
knoxville opened up about the stunt on
howard stern's radio show
yeah i got a brain hemorrhage from that
so my cognitive abilities were in steep
decline after that hit
he added i got really depressed and over
focused on things i did have to start
medication for the first time in my life
so it's hard to find the joy and seeing
the bull throw him in the air knowing
that the ramifications of the scene were
pretty severe if this film has taught us
anything it's don't try this at home
kids even if you do have a lovable group
of rogues around you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]